There's the People's Republic of China
that's a different country,
like seriously,
a different country,
right?
Different tradition,
different language.
How many people died in China under Mao?
No one knows.
Same issue with the Soviet Union.
Although Myra was a bigger monster than
Stalin and that's,
that's impressive.
You know,
because there's Hitler,
there's Stalin and Mao and of the three
mile was probably the worst.
He's still revered in China.
Maybe that accounts for their affinity
for North Korea,
which could still destroy us.
All the remnants of that horrible state.
Maybe 100 million people died in China
during the great leap forward.
That's a hell of a leap forward.
Well,
maybe it wasn't 100 million,
you know,
maybe it was only $40 million,
but as I said before,
when you're counting in the tens of
millions,
your points already made.
And then there was Cambodia and the
killing fields and Bulgaria in east
Germany and Romania and the Democratic
People's Republic of Korea.
That's North Korea and Vietnam and
Ethiopia,
Hungary,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
There was never a successful communist
state cube I suppose came closest,
but it was radically,
um,
the Soviets poured money into Cuba.
So that doesn't really count.
So then the first question was,
well,
are these Marxists motivated by love or
hatred?
Well,
is it love or hatred that produces 100
million dead people?
Is that enough evidence or not?
And if it's not enough evidence,
if you think to yourself,
well,
that's not enough evidence,
it was never really given its proper,
a proper try.
It's like,
well,
why would it been a proper try?
See,
I always think when I hear someone say
that I know what you think,
you think in your delusional arrogance,
that you understand the Marxist
doctrines better than anyone else ever
has,
and that if you were the one
implementing those doctrines,
you would have ushered in the utopia.
That's what you mean when you say that
and no,
they're there.
They saying there's an idea in the new
testament that there's a sin.
It's a sin against the holy ghost.
If you commit that sand,
no one really knows what it is that you
can't be forgiven,
and I would say,
well,
if you want a candidate for the sin
against the Holy Ghost and the 21st
century,
uh,
the statement communism,
real communism was never tried with the
underlying idea that if you had been the
person implementing it,
it would have worked.
I think that's pretty good contender for
something for which you should never be
forgiven.
All right,
so that's Marxism.
So let's go onto postmodernism.
We talked a little bit about it.
Now,
hypothetically,
it's an attitude of skepticism,
irony towards rejection of grand
narratives,
ideologies and universalism.
Crit criticizes objective notions of
reason,
human nature,
social progress,
absolute truth in objective reality.
It's predicated on the idea that the
reason that you categorize especially
that the reason that you categorize is
to marginalize you,
categorize,
to marginalize,
to obtain power powers.
Pretty much all there is.
There's other elements of postmodernism.
One of them is that human nature is
merely a social construct.
See the reason for that,
as far as I'm concerned,
and this is a postmodern critique as
well,
I'm going to move the center to the
margin and the margin to the centers.
Why would you think that human nature is
only a social construct?
Well,
here's why.
It's because that means you could
construct it any way you want to thought
it was a very common idea among this,
among the communists.
You know,
they.
That's why Michael wanted to wipe out
Chinese history.
That's why the red guard wind around in
China and trying to destroy everything,
every element of China's history prior
to approximately 1960 at that great
culture.
Thousands and thousands of years old as
well.
So you could bring in the new man.
But what does the new man.
Well it was whatever slave now happened
to fantasize about or it was the utopian
person.
You take your pick,
but like I said,
if you take a look at the corpses,
you can pretty much figure out which of
those two it was.
So what's up with these people?
These deconstructionists sees
postmodernists.
What are they up to?
Exactly,
but here's the first thing
they came about pretty much when Marxism
was no longer credible,
no longer tenable as an intellectual set
of intellectual propositions.
Now,
if you were a French intellectual,
you had to have a lot of corpses piled
at your feet before you were willing to
think that you were wrong.
So here's an example.
I don't remember his name.
He was the architect of the killing
fields in Cambodia.
It wasn't Pol Pot,
it was one of his advisors.
Unfortunately,
I can't remember his name.
He took his phd at the Sorbonne and he
developed the thesis in the Sorbonne
What Marxists thesis that the cities
were parasites on,
on the land.
You know,
it's an extension of the whole
bourgeoisie proletarian thing.
The cities were full of bourgeois types,
educated and educated parasites
essentially who were doing nothing but
stealing what was rightly the farmers.
So when he came back to Cambodia,
he put that into action and emptied out
the cities and put all the intellectuals
and the city dwellers either to death or
to work,
which generally resulted in death and
killed about one six to one quarter of
the population,
but he got his phd from the Sorbonne.
That's a good story because that's
exactly how complicit the western
leftist intellectuals were in
facilitating the horrors of the 20th
century and it's not like we've learned
anything since then.
Quite the contrary,
but just gone underground and that's
what I see.
That's what I see when I see
postmodernism.
So what happened was,
okay,
despite the affinity of Western
intellectuals for Marxism,
maybe because they weren't paid as much
as bankers,
let's say if we're being cynical about
it,
because the thought that if you paid
sociologists as much as investment
bankers,
they'd be capitalist very rapidly was.
Which is also to say that you may
underpay intellectuals at your peril and
you know that's actually dangerous
because one of the things that's
happening is that as the universities
have become corporatized and corrupted
in a variety of ways,
more and more of the professors or
adjuncts,
right?
I think it's up to 30,
40,
50 percent,
something like that.
Now they've got no tenure,
they've got no job security and their
paid like $24,000
a year.
It's not a good idea to radicalize the
people that are teaching your children,
but anyways,
by the end of the sixties,
so much data on the catastrophic
failures of communism had accrued that
even the most intransigent a French
intellectuals had to admit that the Jig
was up.
But that's a problem because that's the
whole ideology,
right?
That's the whole raise on debt.
You,
he says in this terrible Alberta French,
you're going to just give that up.
What are you going to do after that?
Well,
what happened was postmodernism was
invented and so it's a slight of hand as
far as I can tell.
So and,
and with postmodernism identity
politics.
And so the postmodern transformation is,
well,
we were a little wrong with the working
class thing.
Turns out that Communists killed them
all and capitalists make them all rich
and that's actually exactly the opposite
of we predicted.
But maybe there's still a way this could
be salvaged.
How about if we,
we don't say working class capitalists,
we say oppressor or oppressed,
we'll just.
Well just trends transformed the
terminology a bit and we'll start
thinking about all the other ways that
people are oppressed and then and all
the other ways that people are
oppressors.
And then we can play the same damn game
under a new guys.
And now look,
the postmodernists were Marxists.
So let's make no mistake about that.
Derrida himself said that postmodernism
was a transformation of Marxism.
I'm not making this up.
The question is why?
Well,
because you could say what?
Postmodernism is a valid philosophical
school and we'll get into that for a
minute and they make some valid claims.
One of them,
for example,
this is a central postmodernist claim,
is that there's an infinite number of
ways of interpreting the world and that
actually turns out to be technically
correct.
Part of the reason that we've had a very
difficult time building robots,
ai robots that can operate in the real
world,
is because perceiving the real world
turns out to be so difficult that we
really can't figure out how human beings
do it because it is susceptible to an
infinite number of interpretations.
So that's actually correct.
Now I'm not going to give the
postmodernists a tremendous amount of
credit for discovering that because it
was discovered simultaneously in about
five disciplines at pretty much the same
time,
but you give the devil his due.